don't forget our motto don't give a [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ] the less folks we give
the better we will play waited for
[ __ ] mistake
[Music]
Americans
what are the qualities that make a good
leader perseverance dedication
intelligence the will to be nothing less
than the best
Curro Curro ki sulla heat akan saw me
has all of these qualities and more he
dreamed of being the best of hoisting
the aegis of Champions at the
International not for money not for
glory but for the thrill of competition
to satisfy his desire to lead a team to
the top and win but there always seemed
to be something missing something not
quite right the timing his confidence
his team he always had it in him the
potential to be a true leader a great
player a TI champion but the journey was
far from easy this is his story
kuroky was born in Iran but grew up in
Berlin Germany
a medical condition kept him from being
an active child and as a result he
gained the love of video games so I had
like walking problems when I was child
was very hard because when you're young
you have a lot of energy once he
discovered dota he was fully drawn in
and possessed by a fierce competitive
spirit by his mid-teens he was already a
tremendously talented player in 2008
still just 16 years old
kuroky would join mousesports and his
dota career began in earnest he was a
deadly and versatile core with a strong
mind for the game renown for his Mirana
and morphling able to play both the hard
carry and mid lane roll with Kuro Mouse
became one of the teams to beat in the
world and that year he won the
prestigious gosu gamers carry of the
Year by more than half the votes with
success and recognition fuelling his
dream to be the best Kuro found a
kindred spirit in clément puppy Ivanov
who helped him take the next step
the two first met when puppey acted as a
stand-in on mousesports and they formed
a fast friendship
in fact hero was overwhelmed by how
similar his and puppy's goals were as
well as their way of thinking about the
game too
they resolve to create a new team the
result was King surf international who
made their debut at the dota League
Masters 2009 despite one of their
players Vegas being unable to sort out
his visa in time for the tournament
puppey and kuroky faith in each other
was unwavering and king surf won the
event over meet your makers king surf
international continued to develop into
one of the best teams in Europe and with
puppey as their leader and kuroky as the
right-hand man they posted strong
results across a number of tournaments
in 2009 but by the final months of 2009
Kuro keys motivation was slipping he
decided he needed a change and so he
joined meteor makers where he took on a
leadership role in his own rights
at first the change was fantastic Nym
were a dominant force in the scene and
kuroky was once again motivated to win
however just a few months later a very
poor results at SMM 2009 shattered Kuro
keys newfound confidence he realized he
was not yet ready to lead a team on his
own and thus joined puppy's new squad
for the next year so the team was a
serious contender but the results were
not good enough for puppy who wanted
nothing short of perfection so why not
his fence heir contacted puppy
in mid-2011 to join their team kuroky
was confronted with a difficult decision
he knew that if he asked puppy to stay
he would but he also knew he could not
hold him back from the opportunity puppy
asked kuroky to keep playing without him
but secretly kuroky was planning on
disappearing from the scene but when he
contacted the other members of the team
they wanted to carry on with kuroky as
their new captain with renewed
dedication he led them into the dota 2
age and the International 2011 but there
they did not win a single match for the
next six months
kuroky largely stayed away from the
scene occasionally playing here there
however his desire to win a TI and his
passion for competition slowly brought
him back
he played for virtus pro as the team
attempted to qualify for the
international 2012 but they failed to
make it to the events however kuroky was
given a second chance
mousesports come with me was unable to
attend TI 2 and keroppi was asked to
stand in at supports he accepted well
after the tournament I told myself I'm
gonna play again dota 2 since I redid
entrer last year I was very inactive so
I actually made up my mind and want to
play again since I'm starting to enjoy
the game a lot again so I'm really
looking forward to playing it while most
would finish in last place at ti2 the
chance to play a TI once again reignited
croakies Drive to play kuroky would wind
up sticking with mousesports for the
rest of the year his mind for the game
and flexibility proving valuable as he
played a number of roles
despite mousesports rarely making it out
of the group stages
was back in full swing and regaining his
confidence over on navi two slots had
opened up following the departure of
light of heaven and our sart's puppy
offered kuroky the chance to play
support for na'vi he accepted
reconnecting with his partner-in-crime
after more than a year with his friend
leading him once again his skills put to
good use on an elite team and his drive
to win returned
kuroky on na'vi had a resurgence in 2013
a few months after adding kuroky na'vi
were firing on all cylinders with
puppy's leadership and drafting
supplemented by Kuro keys knowledge Navi
were widely considered to be a serious
contender at ti3 for the first time in
three years
kuroky had a real shot at achieving dota
2 glory Navi made the most of the
opportunities anyway so it's Navi can
still just keep going yep now look for
the mid ranks again the double tornado
is keeping a bad play to rabbit and the
silenced
orange one tank called the GG not be
original winner's bracket and yeah
keeping it on him
there's the MPL to follow it up puppies
still alive next room
GG
not be as snatched a bird in the upper
bracket grand finals from the break-up
defeat Navi tore through the event
fighting their way into the grand finals
and a showdown with their biggest rival
alliance with all ten players playing at
their peak level it was one of the
greatest series of dota ever played on
the footage LAN swing uploader but loda
is still alive
satanic opposes hats and of those well
Elias the Swedish mundane force a game
five this is the first time in teait
history that were going to a game number
five they don't have canceled TV he
cancels a big puppy puppies not gonna be
back in the face it got became me but no
boots of travel down they go over the
throne it could be Game four
I'm doing this they need a little more
stuff off that Japanese sentence live it
could be their last stand
then these back he's gonna try to focus
everybody but there's so much stuff the
glaze there's no available
so close and yet so far
kuroky had been just one game away from
fulfilling his dream but in a
devastating Game five he and Navi fell
just shorts
despite the aegis of champions remaining
elusive it was clear Kuro Kees prodota
career had reached a new heights he gave
his share of na vi's 632 thousand dollar
prize winnings to his parents
Solly was very proud did I you so much
since the money I got it's money I don't
need so they gave it to my parents but
for kuroky it never was really about the
money for me it's mainly for fun because
I love being competitively for to me and
for many years he studied psychology in
addition to playing competitively Navi
stuck together and closed out 2013
winning five tournaments they continued
their strong form for the first few
months of 2014 but by March cracks were
beginning to show na vi's play suffered
and their results dipped sharply by the
time TI 4 rolled around an early exit at
7 to 8th place was not a surprise even
for kuroky I was kind of prepared to
lose I didn't feel that we we can win
like even if he would win felt 9fe we
wouldn't go that far this tournament
after two years on Navi it was time for
a change
however kuroky wanted to remain with
puppey and so he joined him at his new
project a player founded org which would
be called team secrets as part of the
new roster kuroky returned to the carry
role proving his skills or not rusty in
the slightest
give me the red page come on
you know you won't do all the fun puppy
boy the big damage will begin for the
quick red red red nope there it is
there is the red pitch in the fountain
wanna play another diamond red paint
however while secret posted solid
results right off the bat puppy's desire
for perfection would cause rifts in the
team fly left the team followed by no
tail to eventually be replaced by evil
geniuses RTZ and zai the move pushed
kuroky back into the support role but
the results would prove to be well worth
the sacrifice after a rocky start at
both DAC 2015 and starladder star series
season 12 secret will go on to win four
of the five events they attended leading
up to TI 5 marking them as a clear
favorite to win the aegis the team was
skilled smart and had momentum this time
surely kuroky would be victorious sigh
in a bit of trouble can he make his way
out there's the ghost scepter
desperately hanging on
be charged and again it'll pay with his
life with no word easy
is going to be nigh impossible for
secret massacred under the blazing guns
of zya
and CT wise endless krantz there's
another
[Applause]
have done it they - Oh secret and they
move forward the fallout was inevitable
with many pointing fingers at kuroky
especially art easy to beat to bring out
the best like s4 and and try to ignore
my hate for crew I could have done more
and I may have contributed to the loss
yeah kuroky shouldered some of the blame
especially for his play at TI 5 but also
stated he was the scapegoat for the
team's failure with both sides digging
in their heels a split was unavoidable
arteezy left to return to evil geniuses
and kuroky decided it was time to move
on while there was no bad blood between
puppey and kuroky it was the opportunity
for kuroky to build something of his own
and take another shot at leadership this
time kuroky was finally ready he led his
team with a firm belief in the mental
aspect of the game
well the mental preparation is the main
part of esports overall I think he
thought or any other game I mean it's
not too much of a physical activity so
it's all in the mind this is about it's
just about being stable in essence
kuroky has shifted focus from being the
core of his team's gameplay to a
different sort of core nowadays I'm
motivated to make my team work for
example I want to be a good captain for
my team and bring them further and have
success with them because it brings a
lot of joy an emotional and strategic
bedrock upon which his team could rely
they can always rely on me at the end of
the day and gain confidence from me
I'm kind of acting as a center of the
beef with these philosophies in hand
kuroky said about building his new team
dubbed five Jung's he sought out young
players with tremendous talents he
selected fada
Mutombo man jer axe and mind control and
forged ahead in making his new
hand-picked squad a contender even after
being picked up by Team Liquid kuroky
and company posted a mixed bag of
results for the remainder of 2015 in the
beginning it was quite difficult for me
to get adjusted to my position but by
now I I do enjoy it it's so like quite
stressful at times but it's very
rewarding so by early 2016
Kuro keys dedication and patience was
starting to show dividends it all
finally came together in March where the
team put up a sensational performance at
the Shanghai major culminating in a
showdown against puppy's new look team
secret sir let me go for the one versus
three play and he will go for it
Kuro immediately the target the shock
wave goes off first now we're heroes but
now puppy's gonna be able to join them
he gets the deuce on him a toughie man a
snowball say for the moment me but it's
Colonel F he's already cleaned up - and
now the Chase Begins how many other
heroes can they get a nice long range
ice shards from Derek's he knows he's
giving up his own by putting Manchus to
save Mutombo man by blocking in eternal
Envy yeah the sub trick is gonna fall -
but still not enough on the other
shackleshot we ha he showed it big in
the bunker down here their face but now
we ha is gonna be able to make sure it's
a total wipe and there it is
congratulations team secret taking four
in one of the most dominant fashions
we've seen in the grand finals in just
six months
croaky had led a brand-new squad to
challenge his old friends superstar
roster in the grand finals of a major
while the end result was disappointing
it was validation for Kuro keys
leadership style effort and decision to
split from puppey and create something
of his own liquid kept at it becoming an
elite force in the european scene kuroky
was learning more and more about being a
captain and a leader as the players
under him grew more and more experienced
and comfortable with his new system
winds at epicenter 2016 and second place
at the manila major were the rewards for
their efforts finally it was time to
face ti6 while a few of the players had
never before played on dota 2's biggest
stage kuroky and liquid were still
confident they could make a splash
things however did not go according to
plan three for three flows back but the
racks of bull leapers she's gonna get
the objective
[Applause]
clearly something still was not quite
right kuroky had learned much in his
first year as a full captain but the
aegis was once again out of reach he did
not give up liquid was his team his
players they needed him to keep going
keep teaching them he knew they could
get there but first a roster change was
an order fada decided to step away from
the scene for a while and jerax left for
OG in a blockbuster move liquid picked
up one of the hottest players in the
scene miracle a few months later gh was
brought in as the final piece of the
puzzle with the new roster in place
kuroky had everything he needed to
finally reach the top we have approached
self
trying to trust each other and believe
in each other and especially like
believing and the decision-making of
pool and its rafting abilities liquid
surge to the top of the pack and they
began to win a lot
kuroky received heaps of praise for his
steadfast leadership drafting savvy and
relentless work ethic as liquid racked
up the hardware I think in case of our
dota team
kuroky is that building block he not
only does he drop and lead in a game
he also performs an incredible amount of
duties that would normally fall upon the
coat
with such a dynamic and skilled team he
was not going to let this chance slip
away and then it was time the
International 2017 everything kuroky had
done in the past two years everything he
had learned and worked for had led him
here in the group stage liquid looked
unstoppable but kanonji be really hard
without Poppa reps in the game that is
the question miracle picks up the double
kills he takes down the Patna TGG is
called it's finally over as liquid can
pillows it up and we'll open up T eyes
run with AB that getting a 2-0 victory
against IG B that's gg they already say
already done because in the meantime
what we didn't see with my control I'm
Superman just didn't care I was watching
this it was like they just didn't care
GG's called yep that means that liquid
goes into the final day they have one
more match to go they are 11 and 3 let's
play again see but then their confidence
got to them
liquid are down there now a corpse
that's being punched kicked and about to
be put six feet under IG have the
buybacks that they need the makeup the
damage
they've got the control the position is
theirs the game is
the series is theirs and top six is
kuroky was not pleased but liquid had
another shot they were staring down the
long a difficult road of the lower
brackets
kuroky did not allow his team to misstep
again
[Music]
can they kill her once the base is
crumbling stop it damn fantastic
don't return my control pop that me gave
me he's down to half can actually cure
[Applause]
the last time he was here kuroky had had
his dream ripped away from him but this
time however destiny called
this time was the right time the grand
finals of the international seven begins
with newbie vs. team like the end of a
quick game 1 unless you be full of some
absolute miraculous phone play
[Applause]
he's gonna try to front the backline
blakeperez strike holding miracle into
position benefit to all boys down the
mat avoid the booty couldn't get it off
for control
[Music]
their defense here a movie without the
infant does it because they just another
damage of Gigi
[Applause]
kuroky was once again one game away but
even though he had it all in his hands
he would not allow his team to lose
focus
he knew the job was not done
[Music]
volusia county back down
[Applause]
we're gonna be enough alone
maybe the regeneration of
fate gave the shackling forever
- why
[Applause]
absolutely fantastic after seven years
of struggle ups and downs shattered
confidence and roster rebuilds kuroky
had led a team to glory he had finally
succeeded he had won the International
today kuroky and liquid are still
working and still winning having
achieved his dream kuroky has now set
his sights on repeating as a TI champion
he's one of the only three players to
attend every TI he's won the most money
of any esports player ever but like we
learned before for kuroky it's not about
the money
there's a reason after all these years
all the heartbreak and all the struggles
he's kept going still as it's always
been it's always been the thrill of
victory the love of competition and the
joy of leading a band of brothers
forward perseverance dedication
intelligence the will to be nothing but
the best these are what define a true
leader these are what define a dota
legend these are what define Corki
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]